In the last video we
explored when you pay a
certain amount of money
on a per gallon basis
at the pump, how does that
break down who get what?
How much of that goes to the gas station,
verses the transportation
network, verses the
refineries, verses the
actual oil producers?
The one thing I do want
to emphasis is I just
use that as kind of indicative numbers.
They can change widely
based on what's going
on in the market, and
where we are in the world.
They are fairly
indicative. The other thing
I want you to realize is that they aren't
always proportional.
It's not like that if oil
prices were to double
that this 15 cents that
the retailer got would turn into 30 cents.
In general, regardless
of the price of oil,
at least in the United
States, the retailer
tends to get between
5 cents per gallon and
20 cents per gallon. It's normally in that
10 to 15 cent range.
Some of that has to be
netted against the 5 cents or so that goes
for credit card processing. Taxes can be
relatively fixed. It's
often on a per gallon basis.
The spread that the refineries gets, it's
also not necessary
proportional to the price
of oil. There are times
where the oil prices very
high because their
might be a lot of excess
capacities at the refineries.
Their not able to charge a huge premium,
or maybe their not able
to get a lot of the
other stuff. The refineries
might not be able
to make much if anything
on each barrel of oil
that they actual refine. Sometimes it goes
the other way around. A low price of oil,
if the refining capacity is really tight,
the refineries can raise the
price of the actual refined
oil products. They can
raise more and more money.
The players in this whole
supply chain that do,
whose profits are a
function of the price of
oil are the oil producers.
Just to be clear,
sometimes all of these
are owned by the same
company. That's what they
call these kind of vertically
integrated oil producers.
Sometimes they are
different players, and
when they are different
players, the ones that
makes the most when oil
prices are high are the producers.
These producers, they
invest huge amounts of
money in exploration and then in drilling.
They make some assumptions.
They say, "Hey, this
oil rig that I'm going
to spend a hundred or
two hundred million
dollars on, this is going
to be break even if oil
prices are say $30 a barrel."
Obviously, if oil prices
end up being at $100 a
barrel, they're going to make a killing.
They're going to make
$70 per barrel of profit.
This thing is going to
produce millions and
millions of barrels. On
the other hand, if oil
prices go down to $15
per barrel, they're going
to be killed. They're
going to take a huge loss
on this huge investment they made.
The one question I want
to at least attempt to
address, and it's not a simple question.
Many people devote their careers to this.
What is actually dictating
the price of oil?
We see it can't be just
the traditional supply
and demand, or at least in
the short term it can't.
If we look here at 2008.
In mid 2008 oil prices
were pushing $150, and
then only a few months
later they had collapsed to $32 a barrel.
They had gone down by a factor of 5.
There is something that happened here.
The financial crisis
hit, obviously, peoples
expectations of global
growth would have been
gone down. The economy wouldn't grow.
People might use a little
less energy, a little
less fossil fuels, whatever. That wouldn't
be enough to justify a
5 fold decrease in the
price of oil. Something else is at play.
As you can imagine, a lot
of it is just going to be
the psychology of the crowd
right over here or the
psychology of market.
People were driving up the price of oil,
and over here people freaked up, and they
started driving down the price of oil.
To think about that in a
little bit more concrete terms.
I mean think about the
price, or I'm going to
think about the oil markets
in particular in the long term
and short term, or the
long run and the short run.
In the long run, let me draw the long run
right over here. In the
long run we can think of
the oil markets like
you would think of any
traditional microeconomic market.
Oil is entrusting because
it's a microeconomic.
It's one good or service that has huge
implementations on the macroeconomy on the
growth of nations, how they
act, and whatever else.
We can think of it in kind of classical
microeconomic terms.
That's the price of oil.
That's the quantity of
oil. You can imagine
that those first few
millions of barrels are
fairly cheap to produce, and then every
incremental millions of barrels.
If you think about this,
this is the quantity
the millions of barrels per day.
They have to go explore finding it harder
and harder places, using more and more
technology to find it,
so the marginal cost
of producing incremental barrels goes up.
Another way of thinking
about this, at a low
price, oil producers
say, "Hey, I'm going to
leave that oil in the
ground. Why should I pump
it out and produce it
now? So there won't be a
lot of quantity produce."
At a higher price they're
like hey, we're going
to pump as much as we
can. We're going to find
that oil wherever it
is. We are going to pump
it and get it to the market.
Two ways to interpret the
long run supply curve.
Long run supply.
The demand, also, we
can kind of view it in
kind of a classical way.
Those first few millions
of gallons, a huge
benefit to the consumers.
There are some people
that maybe oil is the only
thing they can use. They
can't go to any source
of energy. They get
huge benefits, but then
the marginal benefit goes down for every
incremental barrel of oil.
Another way of thinking
about it, at high prices
there aren't a lot of
people who are interested
in doing it. They
say,"Thank you. I'll just
go use something else.
I'll use solar power,
I'll walk to work, or whatever else."
Then at low prices they
say, "Hey. I'm going
to use all the oil I can
use. I'm going to drive
my gas guzzler 100 miles to work. I'm just
going to drive it around
the block for fun.
I'm going to leave it
running, because I don't
like to start my engine,
and all the rest."
This kind of gives you a classical model
downwards-sloping demand curve, and an
upward-sloping supply
curve. Then you would end up
with some equilibrium
price in the long run, and
some equilibrium quantity.
This right over here
does not describe this
all too well. Between
here and here you did
not have dramatic changes in
how people ... the amount of
oil that supplied into the market.
You did not have dramatic
changes in peoples
behavior in terms of how they consumed,
or where they consumed
a lot or a little of it.
One way to think about it
is this is the long run.
Think about dynamics in
the long run, if there
is new technology to
find new oil to supply
curve could shift to the right like this.
If for whatever reason
people start driving
electric cars, then the
demand curve could shift
to the left like that.
If for whatever reason
it became fashionable again for people to
drive SUVs, the demand curve
could shift to the right.
If countries economic
growth accelerates, if
people in India and China
end up becoming wealthier
and want to buy more
combustion automobiles,
it could shift to the right.
In the long term you can
think about it in that way.
If there's more drilling, if there's eases
regulation on drilling,
you could shift the supply
curve to the right. If
you increase environmental
regulations, supply curve
could shift to the left.
You could figure out the implications.
That's not what's really
at play in the short run.
When I think about the
short run, I'm not thinking
about on a second-by-second
basis, the short
run is really we're
thinking on over a period
of months or even a small number of years.
That's because people aren't
changing their behavior
dramatically on a month-to-month basis.
They already bought their cars.
They already bought
their gas-guzzling SUVs.
Also, it not easy for
suppliers to turn capacity
on or off in the very short run.
In the short run our
model might look something
like this. Obviously, these are gross over
simplifications, but
they help us think about
it a little bit. This is the quantity.
This is price, so in the
short run, the quantity
supplied is really not
going to be too sensitive
to price. It might look
something like this.
I'll just do it as a vertical
line just to really state
how in the short offering,
over a of months,
people are just going to pump
out the oil that they were
planning on pumping on. Their
not going to shut wells.
Their not going not use
their tankers or whatever
else to transport their oil.
Their going to produce,
and it's going to be
transported to the market.
This is the short run
supply curve, regardless
of the price. In the long
run, if the prices go
down they might decided to
turn off capacity. If prices go
up they might do more
expiration, open up more wells,
but that takes time.
Often years to do that,
especially if you start
from the expiration phase.
This is supply not too sensitive to price.
Demand might look something like this.
Once again this is one
way of thinking about it.
A very simple model. Demand
might look something ...
I'll do it in orange. Might look something
like this. Where is
goes ... looks something
like that. The reason I
drew demand that like,
is it kind of fits at
least people short term
behavior. If our price
right now is right over
here, if it were to
pop-up right over there,
in the short run, people
don't change their
behavior that dramatically.
Their house and
their work is the same distance.
It's takes them a while
to start thinking about
moving a little bit closer, changing jobs,
maybe getting a pass for
public transportation,
or trading in their
gas-guzzling car for another
car, or car pooling, or whatever else.
If prices go down, the other way around.
They might still have their Prius.
They won't trade it in
for a more gas-guzzling
car, et cetera, et cetera.
What this describes
is in the short run
the prices aren't being
dictated by these classical
mircoeconomic inputs
or factors in terms of supply and demand.
What's really effecting
them in the short term
is market psychology,
and this is why I put a
little picture of Chicago Board of Trade.
Which is where they
trade futures contracts.
Futures contracts and
I've done video where I
go into detail on what
futures contracts are.
They are a way of trading commodities.
Instead of people
walking around with vials
or barrels of oil and
exchanging them, they say,
"Here's a contract to
purchase oil from me in
a month, or at a specific
date, or two months
at a specific date." People trade those.
In the near term, what's
really driving the price
of oil? What's really
causing these fluctuations
right over here? That
can't really be described
by all of these things,
is peoples psychology, and
peoples information.
They look at things like
the Middle East. They say, "Will Israel,
Benjamin Netanyahu,
Israels Prime Minister,
decide to preemptively
bomb Iran in an attempt
to get rid of their
nuclear program. Will Iran
do something crazy? How
would they retaliate?
Would they try to close off
the straight of our moves?"
Even if no one really
believes that is happening,
some of them might say, Well someone else
might believe it." They might
buy the futures contracts
and then try to trade
it up, and other people,
eventually, that oil has to be delivered,
they might take deliver
of that oil but not
bring it to market. They
might hoard it in some
way, because they believe
that somethings going to
happen and oil is going
to be scarce at some
point in the future.
The big take away is
all of these things, the
production of oil,
other sources of energy,
peoples behavior, they
do matter in the long
run on the price of oil. In the short run,
we're talking about the
order of 6 months to
over a year. It really
is market psychology.
Some of these geopolitical
events that might
effect market psychology
that's causing these
wild swings in the price of oil.